في نهايه عامها الاول تدخل حرب اوكرانيا
منعطفه معركه الدبابات الثقيله التي تدفع
بها الدول الغربيه الى سهول اوكرانيا بعد
تزويدها بمختلف المضادات وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي اليات غربيه تبدو في عين موسكو
مقدمه لاعاده معركه ستالي قبل 80 عاما
قبل ما يناهز العام اطلقت روسيا حمله غزو
شامله ضد اوكرانيا حيث فجرت اكبر نزاع في
اوروبا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولا
نرى اي مؤشر على استعداد روسيا للسلام
اقتحام القوات الروسيه ترابا اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير العام الماضي دفع حلف شمال
الاطلسي الى مضاعفه قدراته العسكريه في
دول السفع الشرقي وفق مقرراته قمه النيتو
الاستثنائيه
لم يكن يوما اطلاقا موحدا مثل ما هو الحال
عليه اليوم بوتين يواجه بالضبط عكس ما
يتوقعه جراء ما فعله في اوكرانيا
حلف الناتو نشر اربعه كتائب قتاليه في كل
من المجر والسوفاكيا ورومانيا وبلغاريا
تضاف لاربع كتائب منتشره منذ خمس سنوات في
بولندا ودول البلطيق الثلاث دول الحلف
وضعت اربعين الفا من القوات الخاصه تحت
امره النيتو واستنفرت 130 طائره ومائه
واربعين سفينه حربيه من مياه الشمال
البارده الى المتوسط الدافئ مرورا بمياه
البحر الاسود الولايات المتحده من ناحيتها
نشرت مئه الف جندي في اوروبا
قبل نحو عام توقع بوتين ان تكون اوكرانيا
هدفا سهلا بوتين توقع سقوطك بسرعه وتوقع
ايضا ان العالم سيقف غير مبالغ الكرملين
اخطا حساباته كافه
حرب اوكرانيا تدخل عامها الثانيه وسط سباق
حربي محموم بين روسيا واوكرانيا مدعومه من
دول الناتو بين دوله قد تستخدم السلاح
النووي اذا تعرضت للهجومي ودول بعضها
نوويه تمتلك احدث الاسلحه
حان الوقت للعوده الى الوراء والتعامل مع
الوضع بواقعيه وبالنسبه للقول اننا سننتصر
في هذه الحرب لا احد سينتصر الوحيد الذي
ينتصر في هذه الحرب هو الذي يتمكن من
وقفها ومحاسبه مسؤولين عنها
دول ناشئه عده قادره على الاطلاع بدور
الوساطه لانهاء حرب مدمره اذا قبلت اطراف
النزاع وتنازلت عن شيء من كبريائها ردين
الفريد العربيه